[Música]
buenas noches
y antes de empezar la charla me gustaría
que nos hiciéramos
un par de preguntas
un par de preguntas en función
[Música]
qué hace que 10.000 personas convergen
en un mismo lugar en una misma
frecuencia que 10.000 con corazones nos
reunamos acá y que hagamos esto cada mes
cada año que nos motiva a reunirnos
buscando la respuesta a esas preguntas
entendido que este tipo
de charlas y escenarios son una
oportunidad maravillosa para compartir
aprendizajes que inspiran
hoy vengo acá con una tarea maravillosa
y es que nos hagamos la pregunta qué
pasó
esa pregunta
qué pasó
en una ciudad de más o menos un millón y
medio de habitantes en la década de los
que mereció el título de la ciudad más
violenta y peligrosa del mundo
pero qué pasó en esa misma ciudad para
que tres décadas después fuera
reconocida hoy como una de las
transformaciones urbanas más importantes
una de las ciudades más innovadoras una
de las ciudades más resilientes y hoy
escenario y anfitriona de la cuarta
revolución industrial pero generalmente
cuando tratamos de escribir a las
ciudades utilizamos recursos como esos
como este tipo de imágenes
pero el peligro que tienen ese tipo de
recursos es que esa es una imagen de una
sola ciudad y olvidamos que estas
también hacen parte de la ciudad en la
que vivimos que hacen parte de la
realidad de la ciudad en la que nosotros
habitamos
y para ponerle contexto al drama de esa
tragedia de haber sido la ciudad más
peligrosa del mundo este gráfico nos
cuenta que sólo entre 1990 y el 2010 en
nuestra ciudad murieron asesinadas
100.000 personas
pero no cualquier
cualquier persona joven es entre los 15
y los 24 años chicos y chicas que tenían
un sueño que tenían una ilusión pero en
la ciudad aprendimos que para
transformar esa historia de dolor esa
historia de tristeza
una historia mediada por la violencia
del narcotráfico
teníamos que deconstruir las maneras de
pensar la ciudad y entendimos tres
principios fundamentales el primero que
teníamos que empezar por el final y
dirán ustedes de qué estará hablando
santiago
el segundo es que algún día no es algún
día algún día soy
y el tercero es que hay que olvidar y
resignificar el pasado de manera
selectiva
miren lo dramático de esas cifras que
solo en 1991 casi 6 mil 500 jóvenes
fueron asesinados en términos de equipos
de fútbol porque esas son las edades en
las que los jugadores de fútbol quieren
construir una ilusión en torno a ese
deporte es como si en medellín o
hubiéramos asesinado alrededor de 350
equipos de fútbol todas las ligas
profesionales del planeta matamos la
oportunidad de que crecieran meses
ronaldos jaimes david ospina chicos que
tenían una esperanza
pero 30 años después esa cifra ha
logrado bajar casi al 10% y ahí nos
debemos hacer la pregunta que hizo
nuestra ciudad que hicimos en nuestra
ciudad para transformar esa historia de
dolor esa historia de tragedia y de
violencia mediada por el narcotráfico y
el terror para convertirla hoy en una de
las transformaciones más significativas
del mundo contemporáneo
pero la pregunta es mucho más compleja
aprendió medellín la lección y puede hoy
medellín decirle a otras ciudades no
repitan la historia no necesitan vivir
la misma historia que nosotros vivimos y
va aprendió medellín tal vez a afrontar
ese reto en generaciones futuras
y vamos a tratar de encontrarle
respuesta y estás imágenes dicen mucho
de las escenas de violencia que se
vivieron en nuestra ciudad una ciudad
donde el miedo se tomó todos los
rincones y todos los escenarios una
ciudad donde se desmembraron no solo los
cuerpos sino las ilusiones de sus
jóvenes de sus chicos y chicas y de sus
ciudadanos
una ciudad donde la vida se derrotó
y desafortunadamente una ciudad donde
unos iconos prevalecieron sobre otros y
la violencia ha terminado siendo
excelente con el que el mundo nos miraba
y empezamos por el final
y ustedes me preguntarán y qué es
empezar por el final y es que
entendíamos entendimos que había que
pensar la ciudad no al año siguiente
sino tres o cuatro décadas hacia el
futuro
entendimos tal vez que no nos íbamos a
poner de acuerdo sobre lo que nos había
pasado en el pasado pero que si nos
poníamos de acuerdo sobre el futuro tal
vez le podíamos encontrar salida a esa
tragedia
y empezar por el final significó
entender esto maravilloso y es que la
violencia no era el problema es que la
violencia era la manifestación de un
problema mayor era la manifestación de
un problema que se veía claramente en
las brechas de inequidad de desigualdad
de segregación socio espacial en las que
vivían nuestros ciudadanos
imágenes como estas de jóvenes que
sentían que no pertenecían a esa ciudad
y entendimos que la ciudad no son los
grandes edificios ni las autopistas de
la ciudad somos las personas y pusimos
precisamente en esa construcción
colectiva a las personas
y pensamos en cómo construir una idea y
una idea colectiva
y tratando de definir qué es una idea me
encontré un filósofo maravilloso que
dice lo siguiente se hacen eternas
cuando las quieren y siempre viven y
nunca mueren cuando se duermen son
indefensas y las despiertan cuando las
piensan las más valiosas nunca se nunca
se venden alcanzan todo lo que deseas
así de grandes son las ideas calle 13 y
en torno a eso construimos
[Aplausos]
y en torno a eso nos reunimos a
construir una idea una idea que era una
ciudad y cuando llegó nos reunimos es
líderes comunitarios empresarios hombres
y mujeres jóvenes niños y niñas se
reunión a pensar la ciudad y entendimos
que las ciudades no las imaginan solo
los gobernantes y entendimos que el
derecho más bello que es el derecho a la
ciudad es la oportunidad de ser parte de
su transformación de su co creación y de
su coproducción
y abrazamos eso entendimos que
transformar un día en la vida de doñana
don jose de catalina de vanessa de
camila es transformar un día en la vida
de las ciudades
pero de qué servía que niños y niñas
plasmarán en gráficos maravillosos la
ciudad que queríamos sigue eso se
quedaba tan solo en un sueño y el
peligro que se corre cuando tú planeas y
los planes se quedan guardando polvo y
esperando un día y entendimos eso si
algún día no es cualquier algún día soy
y entendimos que podíamos transformar un
basurero en esto en un jardín
maravilloso
entendimos que podíamos transformar uno
de los lugares más odiados por centros
culturales parques recreativos jardines
botánicos pero que esa infraestructura
no tenía sentido si la gente no la
habitaba y le daba vida y cobraba vida
como tal
cambiamos en ese mismo escenario del
basurero para volverlo la sede de la
innovación de la ciudad
pero además entendimos que un sistema de
transporte integrado que nos dijeron que
no lo construyéramos porque no le iba a
servir a la ciudad en 1980 lo estábamos
construyendo para la ciudad de cuatro
décadas para la ciudad de mis sobrinos
no para la ciudad de nosotros y hoy en
día esa ciudad es reconocida por tener
uno de los sistemas multimodales más
innovadores del mundo porque lo pensamos
y lo construimos pensando que algún día
no es algún día sino que algún día es
hoy
y hoy cuando ustedes pueden visitar
nuestra ciudad encuentran que no sólo
tenemos un metro sino tranvías y metro
cables metro cables que soñaron los
niños y dibujaron y gracias a ellos nos
nos inspiraron para poder hacer esos
desarrollos
pero además entendimos que había que
llevar esa infraestructura donde no
existía donde los indicadores de
desarrollo humano nos mostraban que
precisamente allí los ciudadanos no
tenían acceso a ese tipo de privilegios
y que podíamos transformar la vida de
las personas y los ciudadanos con
bibliotecas con educación con cultura
con centros de formación de primera
infancia
con espacios deportivos y recreativos
pero una de las cosas más lindas que
entendimos en medellín es que la ciudad
no la transforman solo los gobernantes
es que la ciudad somos todos nosotros y
que lo esencial
casi siempre es invisible a los ojos por
eso cuando a usted le pregunten que es
bogotá parece tranquilo y diga bogotá de
saná
camilo santiago juan manuel porque la
ciudad somos todos y cada uno de
nosotros muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]